Oh
[Music]
we have a great responsibility over this
world
[Music]
the price of freedom is high but we are
willing to pay it
I have seen many futures in all but one
war awaits humans are just afraid of
home
Asgardians thirst for the glory of allah
you humor some wizards folks demigods
let's be civil our realms have been
butting heads for a long time I don't
know about you but if fighting a secret
war will prevent an open one
I'm game will you join me
[Music]
please give a huge shout out and a
welcome to Bill Roseman VP and creative
director of Marvel games yes so ok I
think what on everyone's mind on my mind
yes what is this what does this mean
where are we what's happening what does
it all mean
well this is our new game this is an
idea that we had a few years back and we
started planting seeds in contest of
Champions of this story that was like
loosely based to secret Wars but then we
start thinking this is too big this is
too crazy that should be a separate game
and our complete different experience
contest is doing this thing is growing
as big as has ever been but now we have
a second thing and they're gonna connect
look at this map right here I know we're
blocking it we have house of iron spider
guild you have you ever thought like
gamma horde what did it take what
inspired you to create something this
massive a few things
well Secret Wars 2015 I think was a
massive event and is amazing and I have
all those influences of course I love
dune I love Game of Thrones Lord of the
Rings all that kind of stuff
so I started mixing all these influences
to Marvel and you know something came
came out of it and we bring the MCU
stuff we bring comic stuff out the old
runs the me and bill love you know 70s
Doctor Strange mixed with the new Doctor
Strange so put everything in the blender
and make something special I love it the
contest you know they're celebrating
five years you know in the end
BAM have been so good at creating so
many characters that are iconic and the
fans now spent five years playing these
iconic versions of the characters so now
it's come after five years of okay
where do we go from here and they really
embrace this idea of all these different
alt versions of the characters that are
very much inspired by both old-school
and new-school
so yeah you have like you know
characters invented back in the 60s and
70s but then you have Madame web
inspired very much by Spyder going yeah
so she has this whole mix chock-full of
Easter eggs really based in classic
marble but mixed up I've brought into
something all-new all-different and very
much an extension of and connected to
conscious champion yeah it for us is the
same universe and we want to tell
stories that span from one game to the
other will have crossovers in classic
comic book fashion you know but you know
if you want to just play one or play the
other is completely fine but we see this
as one big universe that we want to
explore so you see you say one big
universe how are they connected in this
universe well we can say too much right
now we're out but if if you play contest
of Champions and you blow the app and
you see the home screen for example
there's a planet in the background all
these years and the plan has been
congealing slowly
that's better world that's already that
story starting of course it's very right
now it's very geeky for us nobody really
needs to pay attention to that but if
you go back now you see the seeds of the
story already arising so that's why it
starts with better world better world is
this patchwork planet well you see
several realities kind of mesh together
into this big ball of trouble you know
so we want to explore those those
stories and love the story
you know everything that we do at Marvel
and command is all about story that's
where it all began up and you've
concocted the story when you think about
from the very beginning when maestro
came on the scene yeah contest and
really led that whole story and and
drove that and now when you go over to
the Kabam booth and you see that huge
statue and it's looming and it says on
his chest spray-painted who killed King
ho-ho and that's where the mystery rides
the story told from people been asking
all this time like when we do the
character maps where as the maestro he's
so important in the story I said like
wait and see we have plans for that and
this is the plans the maestro came to
better world he was left at the end of
act 4 of our story in Barrow to die as a
bear world was cooking he was that play
that was supposed to be a strong world
that was the plan for him but then he
got defeated by Thanos he got left to
die in there and what he was doing all
these years that's what he was doing
so we talked about five years of Marvel
contest of Champions this is the success
of that game right why create a whole
new game well because we can't stand
still what you see will you like trouble
well is like bill said it's all about
story right we had this itch you know
we've been telling this weird like
alternate dimension story in contests
already like this multiple realities
coming together to fight in this battle
realm but we want to tell a different
kind of story now and contest sometimes
cannot fit certain kinds of experiences
so it started with the story and then
after that we'll say like whoa maybe we
want to do something more the contest
cannot do like contest a very solitary
experience right we have your friends
playing with the alliances but when you
go fight is one-on-one against the
computer we wanted to do something as
multiplayer social you can go in a team
of superheroes which is an experience we
miss you know you put your team together
in contests but you only got to play
with one you don't get the interaction
between the superhero so we had to build
a whole new game to get all of that
together
wait a second you were like hinting at
multiplayer yes wait more than ante
because you know you ask why yeah well
everything that Marvel does don't just
start stop with one like what are we
only gonna publish one comic a month oh
right we have nice stories more ideas we
want to give the fans more MORE let's do
more we don't just sell what t-shirt we
have all these teachers are choose from
so it's about choice
yeah it's about story and and we always
want to give different experiences for
everything that Marvel does everything
that we create with our awesome creators
& partners we think about how can we
make this different from this other
thing it's all Marvel rise everything
that you want from a Marvel experience
it's chock-full with all those
ingredients now how can we make it
different so that you can if you want to
play one that's fine but if you want to
play both that's even better now see
connections and everything that Marvel
does that's how we reward people we know
more you grew up with Marvel the more
you see the more you read the more you
watch the more you play we're always
rewarding with expanding the world
building the world and it's really up to
you to write back and forth and soak up
and learn and experience oh that's why
why do you one and we can do two and
there hasn't been but they're both
awesome
of course yeah and there's also
something that we want to do with this
game is we tell very close stories to
contest you you know you go to the story
and you play we want to tell this story
of this game with the players we want
them to be able to influence this world
aligned to us to a house take a
character customize the characters like
once you pick your house you pledge
allegiance to your house your amount of
choice does not stop there right this
game is all about customization yes and
once you're in a house and you have your
your
getting a champion as you play as you go
through you have opportunities to change
your character to make choices to mix
and match and to make it your champion
yeah how deep does this customized
customized they should go it's pretty
deep in contests you can do much why is
the cat is the character you can evolve
the character but for this game as you
get it you get gonna get let's say a
basic Ironman you get the Under Armour
and maybe a mask or arc reactor so you
can still do your stuff but then there's
five the six different slots of
customization six different
customization so you can you can mix and
match you can make your own Iron Man and
different weapons and you can I don't
know what's your favorite Iron Man armor
you know like maybe it's the infinity
war one you can do a full-on inspired by
the infinity war or you can mix with war
machine pieces and see how it goes are
you guys hearing this you can literally
mix Ironman armor and war machine armor
in this you could customize your own
here yes yes but even before that just
to pick your house it's really tough
yeah the thought that the team did in
building all the houses and in their
logos and their names and the locations
and their colors and what they stand for
yes their values what do they do in the
world where they believe in you've made
it really difficult and I've seen people
and even couples torn asunder yes I
believe in this so the choices you have
to make you know your friends may will
probably be in a different house but
each house is food
and strong and everyone can say this is
why yeah why what was it was yours
condor forever
what i'm vishanti i'm dr. strange out
the way i'd have to go with the spider
so you can all pick a different house
yeah what you believe in yeah and they
don't have different ways to play you
know like you if you pick a hook you can
expect to be a tank heavy character if
you pick a Spider Man you're fast and
you everything feels like the character
you you know and love but it's your
version of that character you cannot
fine-tune the experience to make maybe a
hope there's a bit more defensive or
more attacked minded so there's a lot to
do there I know that's a lot microphone
right there oh so I want to talk more
about because this is a new game yeah
the difference is between Marvel contest
of Champions Marvel realm of Champions
because I feel like we have a lot of
Marvel cons of Champions founds out here
what can these fans look forward to well
well customization is one good start you
know no contest 101 101
fighting game realm is a action RPG
teams of 3v3
can go against the computer or you can
go against all the teams you feel gets
other teams yeah but like in real time
your time in real time real time yeah
yeah it is it is very ambitious with
this project and we're working really
hard to make sure that the experience is
really simulus and you can pick your
house sometimes you have missions that
you mix the houses yeah we can have the
Doctor Strange with the Hulk black
panther fighting together against you
know enemies and bosses this is epic
this is epic how how long does it take
to craft a game like this well I yeah I
mean I've been in it because my part is
the creative so I've been like building
the foundations for many years now and
then we push the game to those guys a
couple of years ago yes
visit the offices and see everything
they're developing for contest and then
you know one day we went up there like
whips interesting to show yeah and I was
blown away and I shouldn't be surprised
Gabe is a lifelong card-carrying true
believer we all grew up on the scene in
comics we loved we loved it to sit and
geek out about the things that we loved
so his knowledge and the whole team
would the knowledge of the entire team
right wasn't so deep so the first time
we went up and we saw the materials were
blown away by of course the quality you
know consciousness set the bar but the
quantity the amount of images
world-building the Lord it was so well
thought out and really you're seeing
that today sometimes a game will
announce you know just sealed logo I
mean this is boom oh there's a game
there's a logo here's all the lands
here's all the characters and going to
that picnic house future swag bag I mean
they've been thinking about this and
just been immersed in this for so many
months that it's so well thought out and
there's a ton of content and it's not
ending here
no that's many more all those great
lands around those already houses they
already have planned for the rollout and
they're crazy there's some like really
weird houses because this game that
allows us to be really granular with our
geekiness you know intricate yeah for
Kona for context every time we have to
release the character we have to how we
justify a full character it takes a long
time to build one
but first I'll give you an example I
love the blue mask Doctor Strange from
the 70s right if we were release there
in context we have like why we reason
this now nobody is gonna know it but in
this we'll be releasing more and more
different versions of the the gear so we
can't do all those little things the
knowledge to the different things that
might not be justified in another game
so there's a lot to be you know happy
about if you'd know like really weird
and meesh like characters from the past
I feel like you've gone back to the core
like you said so there was a storyline
in Doctor Strange back in the 70s when
he debuted this kind of all blue kind of
super horse superhuman suit and it
didn't last that long no it was only a
handful of issues but but the fact that
you went back and you started they're
not just inventing something out of the
blue it's like here the suit is based on
this if your player if you if you aren't
familiar with that story it just looks
cool but if you are familiar with it
you're like I know what they based that
is that dr. strange story from the 70s
yeah so that's what's cool is they
they've gone back they've done their
research they've dug back into the the
back issue bins
they've climbed through the Marvel vault
they found all this great ingredients
but they're doing their own spin on it
and has the own contest champions kind
of art style and look to it
and and rebuild it and remix it all
together to create something fresh yeah
okay got you to the candy store right
now and it just chose the trust that you
two have with one another
cabana and Marvel collaborating on this
allowing a company to create and allow
fans to customize their own Marvel
characters that's huge like when a
company comes to you bill and and
pitches this idea that hey we want fans
to be able to customize their hero's
what goes through your mind well I mean
we you know at Marvel games we always
want to say yes yeah if that is cool yes
Bret along with that is is it authentic
is it authentic
does it really represent Marvel you know
and there's certain things we believe in
and we hold true to and there's there's
a method behind the madness of the way
we design our characters the way we
craft our stories that make them
unmistakeably Marvel and not anything
else and so when you work with a team
like Kabam think about the months and
months over five years every month
they've been creating so much amazing
stuff
I mean they've I mean they they they've
earned our day under trust from day one
so now it's five years later and so when
we saw everything they unveiled of
course it was right because we're one
family now one family we heard a cry we
live we look we we live it we breathe it
and so so you that's what we gave them
that trust of yes customization of let's
allow the players to create their
character and we know the the building
blocks that Kabam are going to provide
are going to be completely 100%
authentic marble so it's all win-win-win
yeah it was creating the characters
also about deconstructing the characters
when you give somebody a bass spider-man
you don't want it to be a specific
spider-man because you want them to do
it so what is the basic elements of a
spider-man they can take on everything
else you're not Peter Parker you're not
number Alice here so what is the basic
so we have to go there and say hey what
is the minimum elements of a tour of a
Captain America they can allow people to
just put their own personality in it and
that was really an interesting process
because it made us think about what
makes each character there without
having to put some acts and stuff which
is part of the players experience and it
all results in our tagline usually U is
hear that from the 60s here we said make
mine Marvel what is realm of Champions
promise make Margo mine make Marvel mine
that's written in the wall at the office
right now that's our motto
you know we'll let people take it you
know the story will be told by us and
the players together and if we see the
players going one way if you push it the
other way and see how they respond let's
say one of the houses is really dominant
maybe we put something there counters
them how they'll do the new trap
you know if it's the new villain right
so we want to tell the story together
always watching the players that could
go in with it you know more even more
than contest who doesn't do that already
but this is a living breathing world
that we want to you know build the
players that really shows the love you
have to your fans to be able to give
them this opportunity that's it's it's
stunning to the sky now when you pitch
this when you team [ __ ] this were you
nervous like do you think do you like
they're gonna accept this like what was
going through your mind at the time
[Music]
[Laughter]
you don't know how people are gonna
react of course but you know we are the
same as you know we love all the stuff
so we took it from our own perspective
for all like instinct right and at
Marvel we love when we're working with
great creators and they keep it
authentic and then do the twist we love
being surprised we love seeing something
like ah I never would have thought of
that but I love that's this was it was
just there's one one graphic they
created was just squares and screens of
faces and faces and faces of all the
champions and the Barons and it just
again blew us away with the imagination
shocked us surprised us at first like
what's that
oh I understand where that came from so
that's where it comes from they have the
knowledge they have the love they have
the passion so everything they created
was right on target we love when people
stretch and Bend and try unexpected
things with our characters because
that's what the fans want that's what I
want when I experienced it in Marvel I
want to be shocked I want to be
surprised I want to say oh my god I
never would have thought of that I love
it I don't know what we do with that
bill Roseman I don't know what we had we
were doing at them so we got a team up
we got to talk about your booth five
five six the Kabam booth if you haven't
seen it I mean the maestro is looming
tall you can see it from here so what
can fans do at this booth no it's
perfect size to show people that those
two games are united so one side is the
fantastic
you know all the contest players can
expect great tournaments great swag you
know we're gonna have the similar
showdown we're gonna have the NIACC
tournament like we did last year is also
people playing this gigantic scream and
we're gonna have like a awesome tour to
the top is amazing like the ISIS fear we
wanted to do like that last year we
couldn't do it
and everyone has to see underneath the
trip with the trophy is it up sight to
behold it's a beautiful thing right
underneath it there is from Hot Toys
there's this venom pool figure that is
taken right from the game it's beautiful
well you don't have one you don't have
one yourself get this been available
what is this we have this pimple with a
big statue of the master Oh what does
being graffiti like you killed King Ho
the beginning of our story the more will
be revealed in time that's how the story
starts a stroke getting murdered by
someone we don't know who all the the
houses are suspects in this crime
because they all want the power the
massive political intrigue you watch a
video and you pledge allegiance yeah
this is you go when you put the
headphones on and it's a good five six
minutes experience it takes you into the
world it shows you the cool video it
takes you through each house and you
really get an analysis of of each land
who rules it what they stand for and
then you have to make a choice and you
don't have long and you see all the
Barons lined up and I don't wanna give
spoilers but once you once you make your
choice you you exit and what do you get
yeah we got to show them swag you get so
you guys have some swag do you guys let
some swag so that's what I thought they
could have just made one bag one same
bag for everybody but they went above
and beyond
each
bag is based upon what choice you make
and what house you pledged to so you get
this awesome map an awesome realm of
Champions hat
[Music]
then check this out by this person this
person picked house of iron
and you get a banner for each house you
pledge like look it look at the detail
of this the colors I love that they
really thought it through so you have
the logo and then you have the house
colors and they really put really
thought and effort into this so you get
your banner for the house you pledge and
you get an awesome pin so you can
proudly show everyone which house this
is all three it's all free you just go
to go to the command booth check out
Marvel Roma champions and collect all of
this like mega your choice you can go
through how many times eight you can go
through eight times pick a different
house and get eight banners and eight
pins it's up to you but I mean I want to
have these who wants a pin pin yeah we
go Iron Fist you welcome
and these lanyards so this is again this
really shows the thought they put in
it's just not random faces so on one
side you have the iconic versions of the
Marvel you have corresponding realm of
Champions so here you have spider-gwen
here at the top and there's Madame web
so you go down Thor War Thor Iron Man
back you go Captain America Captain
Carter you've storm apocalypse
yep Hulk you have scar Doctor Strange
for supreme here's two Chawla you're
sure the whole thing how long we go for
[Laughter]
love it I love it
the bills excitement does wrong alright
too late well he can do it everyone sees
bill husband the watching your
excitement to this makes me incredibly
excited because I don't know about you
but I feel every time a new game is
revealed a new marvel anything is
revealed I feel like a kid
friends live in real time the gift
you're giving is insane and I am excited
because I you know I you know I geek out
when I'm here and I'm seeing new
graphics and I go to the panels and I
see new comics I get excited by the the
awesome creators doing their own thing
surprising us again I love to be a
surprise and and when I see something
that makes sense that reaches into the
past that brings something to the future
it's just how can you not be excited
it's cool it's cool it's awesome it's
Marvel yeah in the office for so long
now that I wanted to see out there I
want
reactions you know because I am excited
everybody in the office they're watching
right now I cut them and you know their
website to see what people think they
know everybody so this moment makes it
real for us to it everybody comes out of
really yeah now the only thing we've
been talking about story story story
because we love story but don't want to
underplay the gameplay which we're not
going to talk about now but the gameplay
of course it's awesome and and that
always comes first into any of the games
as would as gameplay how does it feel is
it funny it's awesome it's amazing but
the reason we talk about stor story is
that's what really drives everything and
we'll have more reveals at the Marvel
games Madison Square Garden panel
tomorrow at 3 p.m. so hopefully you guys
are gonna be there there's more you'll
see more graphics more characters the
thoughts that went into making it things
you've never seen before world premieres
will be at the Marvel games panel can't
believe I cannot wait for that msg are
you ready for that he prepared and
obviously we can't forget about Marvel
contest of Champions summoner showdown
finals tomorrow 11:45 in the morning
right here live on this stage nine weeks
nine weeks 27 summoners we've narrowed
it down to nine from all over the
country and Canada can't forget about
Canada and my gosh it has been a wild
ride the most elite players I've ever
seen in my life guys one of them will
walk away one of them will walk away
with the grand prize with with the grand
prize guys give it up for gay 4-0 and
Bill Roseman for mobile Rome of
Champions coming 20 20